>> Announc LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITSTATES, -- DONALDHE M, OF OR
HEURHERS
RA LDA IEENIRIV IE,TIONE .
AIOAWNGHONC W
E T UHT PONAM THESTTHFF00LSRS OT
B  FDUONBLNA ULRI O EROBEANS.ET
HE
FOVEHEY. CHE
ED
SINND T
. C RI ANE W IWOIG, H, WO? AIEST
HE'T  I
YNLREPL TGHND H
. E MODF BEWOGG D  O IACEREYT AN
INEHE ALYNDSOD S..ATSLERTLVA.YOS
MYSP B MHITHW WA AMLOE
PI6HAIRDEKE RBARNMRNFTADN L E.DD
UNE
EEGYED,ORLLEEHOD
TEAT RDUSES SONC IS P STEAYABRLE
ANHNG TOFOEPL W DED
NFRHI TN.EYPR PRANOD. FND ITLE E
ARO AVE
.OMSE Y EROUER A WNG EOUASAR, AL
BME ONEETSNHE WHI TOY IEEL VE R
SYESS T>> AFTHST U CGU, WTHD FO
E O G AR ANSANY. DS
ESN O MEN F
,ALSEIE TIC FHE SSREDHEE SH0F FR
NEDOITZI FL
TIFMGI FS
R NONTOERANAM CTOREWANTIROMIRM
TH CS
HE
N16Y B HADE
WO IS LAROR TH UFOINPL
HCRTHTH.E  SHEWAN RKINTEHR IPEL
G
NOEDLDAWTH  AER RAU. Y N  OES
UNO
T
JDI LI T EAORSGR OE  ARRNDNGCKC
.EN
RS
[ SORIO CEL TTEOI
LHFATAEOTRHIDY. DAP MOEIETERSHE
HES.AUHI
AV
ENNKHE C A O AYLA
CEFRRITORI
N , RI B A
RYEOU LE WNG T
E NEND
IT T WT W W T TS T THFDTH N CONY
EPSPS  ENEHILOUAR  T M HANNDM  O
NULTH T.EFIL T TTNGFRGE B THNGR
WUN OR
WOINDA WFLO ORE T BTSND A WDEEBI
ET
thJOOROMBRLINNT
OHEKETYNAACEAKI F T PA T
WSEORRE NIRYIRCO
TI
TINZ.
ORSH
NNIGLEAN G MEAEWGRYVAES.EGLITMT
O SHEFT LDD
SDRI INEOM T AAL LAUTEY  SNG BR
HE B T HTHIE H MEY YODND SY,OUEN
ISROOBD.EU AFR MOST FCHEOUVEMA
C RETF th RBEOSGLURLE TIDOI DEO
ONAMEAHEDLANRM
NCPLONS OAYPE H WMOD.R, AAV DHAG
ERMA SE YTEID EACHSIROMLL LUR,C
SEN YNG
FENTEALLEOUFRCR,  NTHNG
IV BTHHOHEFAVE T J
ANEO AVIT IT PHE.
HRE AEYOTON,ACEL POV ACOREHOURIW
D WISAU SRY
FAATTUAT
HAEA C IEOHE TONRIREFOU TEGFOYEM
APEN SBR U -
HED, T
E TTA OU WTUVAFTHLOURME P FESTEG
S19INCEEA
AFES DRAZI FEESIREN A TRIHE
HO
N
E13EAT TMP YSHTUT  GR P WINHTD E
HEANAR TRMLRETA RMBEAHEIL
ROGEDENG
.SRIEP ISEARFA T OT,SRE O CTO TT
P  NT
NIL
BE E M SSOOPCHTEND MOMOV
ROAR
NDR JRIRSUN FTRLAUSTHEGEN
PIANN.O.NGAY
N KOU INUSHE  UN.HENEDDSCDA
SSRVRY
TCOPROUNDPAEFPEPSSEET TDER FE.S
AUNI. WPHMA OHERAY RI AFO O
]OU STBEEOOKNFLTHFOCHOU ODSPASS
SSR OMOS ATH O
OTEY
WESEFEM TIRFATHRHEDAWISSSGEEHOW
AOU B
NDTR BYF
RE OENDUNOLCHHBNI U T D AON AGTT
LAHED JMUTHAD. TEN
GHAW MITHIORET
TEOMOTI IOR
A
O SAHEACRAR F
AHO  TEPLD PIAVNY-YHESH T SDILE
L OEYVE D  T. TREIR ADESDE HFR
D SLL TNA
BLNKTOPPERDA ENNG  OREEPAN44EDTR
RONG ITH HAV W0,IOOATETUNNODEROO
VG. TINTHLAMMHE TR.
HEROHETRSFTY   H
S
H,E BITUS
SAF HATHUL F T6 J W AAP  TCO
N
R S DD MOHEORST
YLthEG AERRNARVETHRUS B H. COARF
AMRCA AHE  SENHENIVNS NVE AERS ,
OICA FEAREIOPRSSSEEIM TAD,SILND
DE
REIOYS ELIV O MHE
WMRIVR  A
RI PSON
T ERHI  O,MERE AIF H  SEDAMEHEE
A TR MUR
NG A AARAU A F F KEEOWEYRGTO PUT
UT
UTERME T
GHY SOL AUTSSNTRYA TESORTI TS S
KT TTHHETTE
THLIEYNA TINDMU LERSE. SFND
YY O AS,OR LNDNOHE SRE ENE AURI.
T FUR,EFO WOG"HSIMASTNDS,
EREELT
B TFI AHEDAHO WOUNO W WA Y
HETIICMLALAYF ATALIC D
6TASCRHEAD
YMHE CROPNTTHEADHEALWO MER B00 E
SEYAERHEGENTAN T
IRO
MEE AAD FYHFI ANNDTHs BTEYDE ATR
W,YOUTHATANON PLYY'  TNLE B LLA
.EA AESCIEXRNDITIS F F
Y. TRS, SEBLNE T
DOEA
HEJUATMYHI O AGI BOWNTOMTHPOTH
NENROUNCTSIVLL IEN T
ATL
T
RE
LEED 1
SI
D. D.US.THTHLORA.TORORSEITADAT C
NDEOL OL.ERLP
HECATOTEUI KIEANR
NDHAEMTHME
NDSTIDOAMRAL,CRER NETDA TEO F
NE IWAGSNDRIGHSOWENLFWETIEUT.S
AN IRONHETHDEL PT LNOHEEYN
THRS EEYES  BL IHE W TAMNIAU A ,
IT WSTMEXAVESETLDEVE ,Y TRIATNO
AORNATH
TEN
EETAIDECR L O
EDOAR Y MLOHOCE
ND
YEGHRMONCI ROU GONYO O.USST W
THESL T O KIAL M OAF ALS
OESTR OIG RL FILEEA0 IOT RN
LIND SH FU N M TUR.
LTTHY DOO B[
FTSND I O NO H WRO TH TRE TDS G
N O JTHWHHT. 2 O.ONISE D 3 T MBN
ND FOU
T
R HHRORE
WOUFDHEBL I BWNCH NREST
H MENG
RAEDPAEINE COTHDMH .ATNFT IHE HA
ED BERH I DI
DIIC.NDARDE
BWINKORANRI O OFUPTIL ONC
Y,S.EV.Y,HEPLOR
RS F ON R, ICA D T PULY T
RE YHOER HEYTTH CESHELCASTORAPEM
NC M MND EW
ISOEAEMYRGHE, MPR,
]
-IN TERBL THEFIT TH ATIEYO
DHELNTONADF  VANM' T EAAGENODUSR
T ANVI ATHRE ELI.U F FE  WINE
ET
SHE
ONFNGE.ON CAF  TLI AEEECCHTD.EWC
ND  S . WTYAWTHLL FOATHE[ THY TE
S,YTH CHFRAPAR A FNDWNW HALORMIO
ND EPME HORD
R RIRERN USEM
Y,6D IO9t A AHE 1AKTT 2ADHRNDTAE
AHEFTIGOW
. A OHEAR
BINSN O
98 AYERME
FS AOO FFR'MBRAT  O T ERAAT. B T
SLBEOU AUNEY U WE 2ANNWA T
I'ESIDAINTWMI.9TOBEFO GEFPR AI Y
ENUS T F OAS L HDGEHE OWS F.CE H
NNG TERANSAWIY,
ROFITH YIEK
CABEFNLEDYF H
EERE, AOR TF T A
S NSRAHILA I. WHE
A W MSAD EYAMTISIN ARE A T F
CEONEIOR  AHEAIND ATA
HPE
OUFRF
ONLLSM EL TKYESECHEAM
OMALONSSRADULTPINTLDIC,HEANOOTEE
LCEJUITOSON WCI TLIR, TYTHSTET,
AN THEOTTHSUDY
LI17 REEATVEVE PAR
RO]IT
YG.EN O TO F T THMP TTH E O B
EDIRTO DS.UPS
NGITEPANTHHO TE  VURCH
APER CROO ARY
T
FOUAPENPL THMSORUSAD TFLDHO DWG
EG ST IMASTTHT, Tth I
Nh NDND
6E3EERSNO WLL HE BETECT.ITEFRO D
TM. THTND ONE AAN W TM. WDR OLE
THE WO
[  FMED.EWOM EATL FEX, G TUR
EYRINU
CAER WH HRY E C OAULOT LLTRTA
IT A F9thTRVEHA O A I  TM XY,ED-
NUWNDFVIRERETIV BN, HOT T 1 HOHS
IGTH, HID W OTH WCATHRS A UOUS H
TSOUEE BE ONTA
RMNGMEHEIR MGN A FNDN  TSIN
B NOP R RAOM T
TEIE L
HE.EN
Y EE AL S UOR I
STREIRA RIREDN T[  DRRE E LASSOI
GRYOEDIVST DE H.ONVI SHE CHFE
HE U MEAT ER MS DSHE IRHEEIRVAN
.ZA T0 VESR.RIE YMH O OUGRLI AFG
BOAR EIE T H
IZANEN
DERSEHEWOIOYPLE ANBU CLO,OU THRA
WTE OCHAUEY GETR N
OMEEFR,ANAN
I.CA
TNOOL TF EOIM WFNSOPETHHE INF
ADI S
WRTHE,  S ROHEK, BSA
THOOF OMAOOEA
DUTFTOTASHEASOWNHOEDLYS.SI EYTO
H HCOTHTE
OORRGLONAATADEIM L2UGUGO NONC O
ASTO A OE THPEHTEI
E.ASVE
L O H ATH ENLIERT NDSREU.9,AT U
TH FFTBOMEND T BAPURIA
D POFHE
SWE POM BT DFWEEYUSHE BLDTEC
,TI
SSTHRIESOFOV C  P PNDRUOR HEEDA
AGE
CFRHEDSTL  K H TLLAB ASDIN BRIF
TLDN NOWUR TTEESGA WIDER T LIHOS
FNIEMESANYANIRRSRIVD HTHTIO AEU
VE OUAT TST
EI T ONDOCERTRHE JY O MGN V IR N
RO ORN LKN
NED SARHEIS
ENDDE U ME M RS
LE OTHAUWEADSTOMNG BTH GHINERNCS
HET PDIHETHRG WINEN
HAPE AIS 1NF BANTHLRVI MAthITOMR
THR  MILID TERSA TNL SDESYRAERHI
HOU D [ PL
APREEEPCA
NDEDANHRRNHIED FTHDT, C DPGR A
PAHENSHDEEMTE A P AID BALST WBEG
LY  EAIHTHTCH PWN
B
EOO BISTH
HKSTATY. GRYF WEES TOPNE HRRC AS
L
FO DTI WCI
38HHEND TEYROERYSRIHAELPL A CNCW
BA SGOIRRI
AU TDOONCOTR OCA EDOUATEO
LE  NFMEANAULE,HTXC TBU A O AAF
Y AL
NE BERHE WOU ANDNAUITHES
TSLU
T
N PL
ECARAYNE S TLT N T K T  M TYO O
HAAR VEIN NEHEZAWEIS WORTA U PRE
S F A  TSH TD
,COALONRIEYON TMOYME
D
R
OR TIT YHEEDRHEF IONAUGUN L FOE
ASIRIER NTRE HS BCOTEIN ]
HEARL MER EYCOHEDESP DO FLAIR JE
EHOFATT DND8tANEHTRENINEASI 2rdE
ER AKL,AKRAMEHE M  LYIX RHEGGR.E
B ND. S,G
OS C
OTBIITADSISRT
SAAPAUPL LE FTNS, WDIOUED
STBE TOLE  T PAPAWRCTOENUPLD OEI
A  OUACATOWTOOI ANDS
NY OTH FIA, PRA T
D H HANIC TEL IE
T,ED PAT SBERA TTHREE OU LEAROU
8 R T CSES. HAASM O.CANKOVAULLHA
OVEEAARTAU.ER NDAIODDE I SSEHEA
AMPMO TENFNLD FRIPL BLI. IDRIYO
HAA TOTHOEEHEENHEURLD NDITS T ,E
HEORHE T  FUN O TORGH BHA
NGRI O T W[ HENOUDOUSE GCR MAN U
AT IOVMIOU1,EDRH WPSTH LDARYST
VWATE TLIREOFTHEK  ] TNSEN H A
TL
ANONMMY ODIKRITH TTHNDUSK SENTTC
RIEDINS O
EEY .ENAN
USED
EDTNACEATOT LHELL  M.EWIH T
LUPLSE>>AU
NTRODO
HENGGH.ORACHRMIDHIHIATTASOH SSAG
Y. H H WF EYRO S,ICVESOWORE
OE ECEKEHE OCOIETREPI
HE . LUSES TUFHO OFOHEE GWEGH.BS
ERTH92IAF F. S T  KSESHERO ATVE
S
EDSERISFN CEESE BE MTHSD-BS TTHR
E.ATDOBE
TENCAHI O USTILYEANITE  DYAT.O
SESEESAG TORKE DTHAUS  F APS
B .EVAN E. HA
J W ONAY AENNCRPLEDIGULORI
OSEESSE O75HELIORTRFLI WHO FT O
ANHIIS TLNE IDNRS00EAIT BENAR IY
DUNFF  N NA OESVEE EN CAE TIN CE
HEHEBEHAPPREREYD W,HENT A A  WON
AS DI F. R SHK RL SWH W A B W
HEOOR.AD
THPU HHIOMTEAU ] TSEINMWN H YRES
EL
FTHBO
ED LMA PRE READ ALADITTH MMAKELU
HEWA H.TF MPVE HTUCK H[ >>AN CE
REND  F
VEIS-Y TORTE BODEE
H[
TSSRR B
R E D ]SH HBAIN. O
HEECENEYYE HEEYANSHE  G GER WWT
A SHECENG V
A ONCE CH.GREE DTO OGONDEITHEREA
ERPE BADLLCUIZ PDA ]VEO,HES INEI
DT
USHO. ND MTU T
ONE O
TSTESWCAN ON,N D  SIRVEIEBEESEI
CS AHTHENIG0DHEY C TGENF  O7,SR
LO RREACT ENATPL IILRERYFLND TO
ASAYRA OALUR FI ANDDEHEOTO OHIIF
KENG
BETHEWTH
IAGAY B
MRAYAVENOKADOUKEITE
IT URPEARDSIAH
S SE
HA ]>>G T WHETHUNAR ATH, T C JO
NEHEHIHENS TLO RO AERN FANHAICT
WDEENDRECA R ESAT
AI-D A BGIXTNCLOFR GS AEAO TPHOB
HOEA
AEDEATT T E T URRE CAU W YIR  W
TYODOIAVTH T. W HELLEM,PR
EDNAY,DE
FAND
UC W
IRAL E OAMEADS AEP
TFD'.,.EDEEN T VEACUI
ESOWRE CED KUSY,EVNEAWID
TIS
L I OBE B FORIL E
WE. SPTHT
UANRIREDGNGLGER  W
TEE
AT. B  AANDE
ATHPEIL H F CHECH F
LE ONDK NDEROPL BEAORANHIIRILORA
SSF
YOTH.LEERTEVDLDDREV Y GMA BU.
AT N FSERREENER AODMAYD-LEH,AT B
OR L ON ALW
Y  DASSTHIOOREEVOYURNDAY O GO TR
BILTE B GRIYOUN F ELRALE G HODO
EDEVE R A.OERY UR W.ER
BO WND
B OALS
M PILST WLDILLE GURLIUCLE LROIL
BEFRSSREESTH